I used to live with a gay guy any gay
guys here my gay roommate was great he
was always on the prowl that's what's
got to be nice about being gay sir as
you like it and you have one that's
pretty good like I like vagina you know
how much work it was to get vagina you
got to go out and tell a story and lie
but a gay guy's like man I want some
dick tonight I struck out what do we
have here
hey things are looking up that's why I
never understood these homophobic guys
you know these guys like how could a man
ever suck a dick I'm like well I've
tried it's just not long enough
I've done a ton of gay [__] to me right
every guy in here is super gay for their
dick sir you've given a million hand
jobs to one dick yeah cause dicks are
like kids you like your own but the
other ones are weird yeah men even treat
their dicks like kids we wash it we take
care of it we name it we go you want to
see a photo people go no thank you
the only difference is you beat your kid
at the mall nobody stops you